willkommen zur heutigen sitzung wir
haben heute ein bisschen weniger zeit
zur verfügung weil ich wie jene
geschrieben hatte um 12 uhr 40 oder 45
einen vortrag halten soll
gleich hier drüben raum in 210 über
formen des unmoralischen diesen vortrag
finden sie auch falls ich selbst nicht
kommen wollen aber sich dafür
interessieren ab morgen auf die lowcost
weil ich werde diesen vertrag
aufzeichnen wie üblich und mit folien
hinterlegen
jetzt machen wir ein ganz kurzes quiz
sie haben gesehen es gibt ich habe es
auch ungeschickt das kann man jetzt mal
kurz haben hier machen
zur einstimmung das immer wieder ein
bisschen auf aktuellen stand kommen und
zwar ist die erste frage welche könnte
es lesen also welche logische
eigenschaften charakterisieren die
kausalität relation ich kann es
vielleicht noch ein bisschen größer
machen kann man es jetzt besser lesen so
also identität asymmetrie symmetrie
transit ivi tät was würden sie sagen was
charakterisiert die kausal relation
einfach melden mal ist ein oder mehrere
sind immer richtig was wissen sie auf
jeden fall
da
transit ist diese spannende frage
wollten sie noch was sagen als demetri
überprüfen muss doch mal
und das ist richtig also transit ist
sehr strittig ist da ist das stichwort
die kausale ausdünnung und da kommt das
ganze probleme den rand faktoren wieder
ins spiel hier ein transit ivi täte wenn
sie also hier ein dominostein haben und
hier ein und hier ein
dann ist das noch irgendwie verständlich
aber wenn sie das mal ganz konkret auf
eine situation anwenden und dann mal
viel zeit vergehen lassen dann also es
ist strittig
also deswegen wenn man auf der sicheren
seite sein möchte sagt man nur so metro
identität ist natürlich quatsch und
symmetrie auch nicht also asymmetrie
meint eben wenn die ursache von b ist
dann ist nicht auch bd ursache von aa-
also ein bekanntes ganze nicht um tränen
dass also eine wirkung die ursache von
der ursache ist das sei quatsch
also gehen wir mal weiter hier also was
sind die uhr beginnen kandidaten für die
ontologie von ursachen und wirkungen
situationen ereignisse prozesse
tatsachen substanzen
das dürfen sie sich einfach mal hier
ganz frei heraus melden was kann man
alles als entitäten als als dinge
sozusagen einsätzen für ursachen und
wirkung in der regel ist auch ein
bisschen jetzt offen gehalten also kann
man auch darüber diskutieren
prozesse obwohl hier ja sie sich
erinnern bertrand russell das kritisiert
hat gesagt prozess selbst wiederum setzt
kausalität vor auswahlprozesse ja in
sich auch eine bewegung haben
da müssen wir qualität schon annehmen
damit wir an bord
weitere kandidaten
es gibt noch ein paar
versunken für mit ihrem herrn passen
ja also wie gesagt ich würde jetzt sagen
noch tatsachen substanz sagt kann so ein
bisschen aber substanz ist sehr
problematisch geworden deswegen habe ich
jetzt mal hier raus gelassen also
heutzutage spricht niemand mehr von
substanz als ursachen
man spricht vielleicht von kräften
selbst von kräften spricht heute sind
heutzutage niemand mehr eigentlich und
das problem ist dadurch dass man nur von
situationen tatsachen und von prozessen
spricht man auch nur noch ganz selten
hat ja bertrand russell kritisiert das
problem ist man hat glaube ich etwas die
befürchtung dass man in den erklärungs
begriff in die unter logi von ursachen
dass man da so eine art kraft
einschließt und die philosophie ist nach
john lobb sehr skeptisch geworden und
kräften den kräften auszugehen
man ist da ziemlich neutral das problem
ist dann wiederum das also ein bisschen
das eigentlich ist dasjenige was
eigentlich kausalität ausmacht so ein
bisschen auf der strecke bleibt wenn ich
jetzt nur von situation entsprechen
es kann situation geben die vielleicht
gar nichts hervorruft
ja genau genau als ereignis ist so ein
bisschen der lieblingskandidat natürlich
ist ein ereignis auch immer eine
tatsache also ereignis eine tatsache ist
der überbegriff ein ereignis situation
wir werden das gleich noch sehen wir
werden die zeit haben wir noch kurz rein
zu lesen wir könnten sogar sagen dass
mecki dann auch vielleicht letztendlich
von so einer art situation ausgeht was
für arten von kausalität existieren in
der philosophischen tradition ereignis
kausalität freiheits kausalität logische
kausalität akteurs kausalität agenten
kausalität da war mal was wo sie sich
sicher wo nicht was würden sie streiten
bekannte teures prozent im jahr
muss man das verstehen logische
kausalität ja dass dann der
hinreichenden grund also das ist glaube
ich so ein bisschen das problem der
logischen kausalität wie sieht es mit
akteurs kausalitäten agenten kausalität
aus haben jetzt nicht so häufig
besprochen
diese bedeuten letztendlich genau
dasselbe also ein akteur ist auch ein
agent zur selben ort stammen das ist
eigentlich eine art von freiheits
kausalität so nennt man heutzutage bei
kant hat das kausalität der freiheit
genannt und heutzutage nennt das agenten
oder akteurs kauf sollte das ist die
kausalität für einen freien wesen
ausgeht oder meinetwegen auch von den
lebewesen wie dem tier was wir
vielleicht jetzt nicht im strengen sinn
frei würden also logische kausalität ist
ein bisschen das problem dann noch eine
event kritisiert
die qualitäts relation also entweder es
gibt es mehrere möglichkeiten qualitäts
annahmen beruhen auf bloßer gewohnheit
kausalität ist ein psychologisches
phänomen die notwendigkeit der
kausalität lässt sich nicht empirisch
rechtfertigen qualitäts gesetze
passieren auf induktion kausalität lässt
sich empirisch nicht erkennen kausalität
kann physisch erfahren werden abfolgen
von konzeptionen liefern nur was
informationen aber nicht weil
informationen
es gibt noch viele weitere ja ja wir
haben die erfahrung nie so was wie
strikte notwendigkeit dass es immer so
sein muss
weitere kandidaten
und das nächste kausalität lässt sich
empirisch nicht erkennen warum würden
sie sagen ist es falsch ist ein bisschen
ist ein bisschen ist die die frage was
mit erkennen jetzt gemeint ist wir
kennen aber es jetzt mit erkennen
gemeint ist wenn man ob eine gewohnheit
ob es eine induktion erkenntnis ist eine
erkenntnis jetzt im strengen sinne von
objektiven erkenntnis dann wohl eher
nicht nur physisch erfahren werden wie
sagen was sagen sie dazu kann es ein
bisschen schwieriger formulierung ja ich
würde auch ihr sagen nicht abfolgen von
perzeption liefern nur was informationen
aber nicht weil informationen ist das
richtig oder falsch ist es die jungs
kritik also das so sagen könnte
dann liegt jemand soll ich mal hier
klicken und überprüfen ja alle das ist
so eine formulierung hier unten also wir
wissen nur was da ist
rot-grün hart weich sind es daten aber
wir wissen daraus nicht dass diese
qualitäten jetzt sind weil etwas anderes
davor war
wir wissen immer nur das was als diese
faktischen informationen jetzt haben wir
noch eine letzte frage was kritisiert
kann an jungs jungs qualitätsverständnis
kausalität ist ein reiner verstandes
begriff qualitätsbegriff stammt nicht
aus erfahrung macht es möglich
kausalität ist eine bearishe begriffen
ja es gibt noch einen den kann auch der
erste genauer qualität ist ein
empirischer begriff würde kann streiten
jung hatte versucht kausalität als einem
tierischen begriff aufzuzeigen aber es
ist ihnen nicht gelungen
wir haben doch noch zwei fragen welche
vier ursachen kennt aristoteles das
jetzt einfach form stoff gehalt gestalt
und trug ursache form materialeffizienz
und zweck ursache form material wird und
zur sache das ist jetzt sind jetzt
jeweils vier immer natürlich aber es
gibt nur
wird sie das sagen
ich habe da so ein paar kleine fehler
eingebaut
ja genau was ich hier eigentlich
ausgetauscht haben ist einfach normal
effizienz und wirklichkeit hier und
deshalb dass das des elbe genau und
gestalt ist halt eigentlich ihr form
also hätte man zweimal so die form drin
das heißt hier fehlt einfach noch
letztendlich das ist es ist richtig und
das ist richtig
hier fehlt noch beim ersten fehlt noch
die zweck ursachen und das ist eben
nicht die gestalt weil die gestalt auch
die form bislang als überprüfen mal
richtig eine frage haben wir noch so
durch wer das was kritisiert wird
russell an dem qualitätsbegriff
kausalität gesetze lassen sich aufgrund
der komplexen randbedingungen nur schwer
formulieren oder kausalität gesetze
basieren auf induktion oder qualitäts
begriffe sind a priori
ich weiß jetzt auch nicht mehr jetzt
muss ich auch über dinge
also eines ist glaube ich ganz klar das
ist das wofür auch röslers kritik
berühmt ist
ja
da sagt er gar nichts drüber sie ja
genau also ich glaube dass das ist über
induktion sagt er nicht so viel über
vielleicht am ehesten ich weiß jetzt gar
nicht wieso mal auswirken haben sie
sonst an vorschlag zum auswerfen werden
also über die induktion das apriori sagt
er gar nicht so viel
er sagt eben nur eigentlich dass sich
kausalität gesetze nur schwer
formulieren lassen weil eben immer noch
zusätzliche faktoren kausal eingehen
in diesem übergang und das sind so viele
faktoren teilweise dass wir die
vielleicht gar nicht alle aufzählen
können ja dann kann man sich fragen ist
das system isches problem können wir sie
prinzipiell nicht alle aufzählen
und es ist ein auto logisches problem
das einfach so viele gibt jedenfalls war
das das quiz und wir haben fast alles
richtig
irgendwie ein eines nicht richtig
gemacht aber das können sie aber zu
hause probieren falls sie es noch nicht
probiert haben
so jetzt gehen wir aber hier weiter und
kommt auf diesen denker hier zu sprechen
das ist john leslie mackie und die
geburtsdaten sind richtig und kerstin
conditions hals dieser aufsatz und ich
habe deswegen jetzt in der letzten frage
die wir hier aus diesem quiz behandelten
bertrand russell noch einmal genommen
weil wie mir scheint diese kritik von
rasse also dass wir eben hier so eine
menge an bedingungen haben haben wir das
ist jetzt das ereignis und haben wir
noch eben randbedingungen 1 an
bedingungen 2 usw
das dann zur wirkung führt da setzt
jetzt mecki an an diesem problem der
randbedingungen
so was muss alles noch mit in diese
ursachen dieses antike ins der ursache
angehen
das ist die frage damit die wirkung
hervor gebracht wird und wie kann man
das logisch jetzt darstellen also ist es
jetzt ist das ist jetzt das ereignis
hinreichend für die wirkung
offensichtlich nicht weil eben noch
randbedingungen mit hinzu kommen ja dann
kann sich fragen ist es denn notwendig
und wie ich es da das haben die
randbedingungen also sowas das ist jetzt
das problem wir haben ein paar
leitfragen wie knüpft mackie in seiner
theorien russell terrier qualität an was
bedeutet das akronym - das müssen sie
sich merken wenn sie mecki hören - das
ist das zauberwort das ist diese kurze
beschreibung der kausalität relation ist
matschies theorie überzeugend wo liegen
mögliche probleme tja und jetzt nochmal
einfach mal gerade hier rein in den text
ist inzwischen präsident der manager
bickel dies indes account als shared
that what we often spyker cars ist air
condition lot of this sort of lady
justice to say this account modifikation
and can be modified einwohner des
modified boxplay machmal service factory
canary that much of what the military
college claim simplicity nalco solutions
capital fonds auf die evidenz und wii 2
auf dem web-server kost connection also
wir sind sagt ihr gleich im ersten zitat
wir sind oft geneigt template versucht
zu sagen dass die ursache
grund ein ereignis ist und dass es
wieder was sie gesagt haben er spricht
hier eben von ereignissen er spricht
jetzt nicht von situationen von
prozessen oder so weiter sagt ein
ereignis das ein anderes ereignis einem
anderen ereignis vorher geht von dem es
die ursache ist und dass es sowohl
notwendig als auch hinreichend für die
für das auftreten der folge dass -folge
ereignisses wenn man das jetzt mal vor
man formalisieren wie müssten wir das
dann machen haben wir die idee also nach
dieser auffassung
ich habe jetzt hier ursache wirkung wir
müssen das dann formulieren wenn es die
notwendige und hinreichende bedingung
ist für die wirkung das müsste ich dann
machen also wenn es eine hinreichende
bedingung ist dann reicht dieser pfeil
hier das eine implikation also wenn dann
b aber er sagt es ist notwendig und es
ist auch noch notwendig ist nicht nur
hinreichend sind auch notwendig das
heißt ich muss hier einiges an wie
konditionell machen oder also ist
eigentlich so ein notwendig und
hinreichen ist eigentlich so ein
doppelpfeil und das ist häufig seine
auffassung also manche würden auch nur
sagen
ursachen sind eben nur in bereichen
verwirkung aber er wird jetzt sagen hier
das reicht einfach nicht aus also da
gibt es schwierigkeiten und er sagt
jetzt er wird jetzt zeigen dass eine
ursache nicht so verstanden ist damit
nur verwandt ist mit dieser mit dieser
formalisieren
es muss modifiziert werden und jetzt
wollen wir schauen wir diese beziehung
hier kanalisiert und jetzt gibt ein
beispiel das ist immer sehr gut auch in
der analytischen philosophie dass die
philosophen hier immer ganz konkret
werden die reden da nicht nur abstrakt
herum sondern die versuchen das mal zu
veranschaulichen als apostel der fall
has broken outen search im haus was
heißt enix tisch bevor der haushalt
completely destroy experts investigator
chaos auf der feier entdeckt konkret
denn etwas kostbares töten place gott
ist die exact software statement that
has caused the fire klimaexperten
nutzung des computers and conditions
haus catching fire ist ein perfekter das
chance to use somebody over turning
verleidet als darf man auf ein amber of
other things we feed the world have said
the house & fire sale david laws
zwischen condition viertel haus catching
fire that had heard that be no in
flamatt irion ihr bei der feier wurden
not have brought out and even gegenbauer
ist das secure in flammen material der
feier nord have your say the happy end
oder magic sprinkler just rights watch v
vom binger conditions necessary
inzwischen vor der feier des computers
and is now ist nur die exporte have been
like this is another fischen folgt in
lucens dennis tz josef korsten feiern
also was ist jetzt hier der punkt was
bringt er jetzt noch für andere
bedingungen mit ins spiel warum ist
jetzt der kurzschluss nicht er jetzt im
sinne einer ursache so zu verstehen dass
er notwendig und hinreichend warum nicht
was kritisiert er jetzt hier was war der
kurzschluss
für das in flammen stehende des hauses
er war nicht als erstmal hier in
bernhardzell eine pazifische nation also
es ist erst mal nicht unbedingt
hinreichen ne also wenn ich jetzt da nur
so ein kurzschluss habe dann heißt das
noch nicht dass wenn ein kurzschluss ist
das dann ein haus in brand gerät weil
eben hier noch bestimmte andere umstände
hätten sein können
wieso eine ein feuermelder oder eine
sprinkleranlage die eben dieses diesen
brand hätten verhindern können
für diesen war in diesem fall laufen
dort anfangen sich sorgen außerdem weiß
das ganz genau wer ist das schon
genau das ist jetzt an dieser punkt dass
wir eben jetzt hier eine ganz komplexe
bedingungen haben weil wir sonst von
einem ganz anderen fall reden würden
unter umständen
und der anfang
das von einem einfassung zeigen das ist
richtig aber jetzt kommt eben bald zum
nächsten zitat kommt jetzt diese
bedingungen also das ist jetzt das neue
ist dass er das ganze also das ist
notwendig hinreicht usw
dass er das in eine ganz komplexe
modelle form bringt die auch heutzutage
noch standard ist für die kausalität
also wenn jemand ich behaupte jetzt mal
der bedeutendste das bedeutendste
konzept was generell anerkannt wird und
der philosophie ist diese enos
bedingungen also da sind sich die
allermeisten einig sagt zumindest herr
professor nida rümelin immer also und da
kennt sich ja da durchaus gut außer das
ist sehr gut akzeptiert in der
gesellschaft in der philosophischen
gemeinschaft
ja wir müssen jetzt das stimmt schon mit
diesen notwendigen hinreichend aber noch
nicht in dieser komplexen formen des
gefüges von insa fashion is necessary
usw sofort in dieser kombination dieser
verschiedenen modalitäten jetzt noch mal
kurz weiter ellis park auf die ernte ist
der is set of conditions of weeks am
markt positiv und negativ und knuddeln
die präsenz auf dem cleveren materie wie
absence of this place trenkler in not
quite mit combined with complex
condition etwas zu fischen vor dem haus
catching fire fischen button ssl vor der
feier kotev startet in other ways also
zum beispiel eben durch brandstiftungen
also weiter also muss jetzt nicht eben
den kurzschluss sein also auf das konto
von complex conditioner search for
secure sind in dispensiert
die adapter auf das condition conjoint
mit in die erstens auf das stück you to
use the fire that you have caused the
fire ist das ein display port of complex
zwischen bad noten es ist herr condition
of fire
das ist jetzt das entscheiden also das
müssen wir uns noch mal kurz
vergegenwärtigen also der kurzschluss
von dem man sagt dass er das feuer
verursacht hat ist ein unverzichtbarer
teil einer komplexen hinreichenden aber
nicht notwendigen bedingung für das
feuer
also
ich denke dass der strom steht nicht das
zweite tor der kiwis stimmen
hintereinander
der sportausschuss catching fire
summieren das ist einfach wichtig ist
dass das aus das ist im hausgang
vorliegen und dann legt über zwischen
von überall vorkommen wird was wäre
beispielsweise vier speziellen die uns
freude mit dieser entwicklung im zweiten
gehört
andere das also nicht guter punkt also
dass man hier unterscheidet von dem fall
grundsätzlich dass das haus feuer fängt
oder das haus genauso feuer fängt
das ist dann dieses demonstrativ dieses
dieses feuer
also ein schwelbrand zb ein schwelbrand
denn wenn irgendwelche drähte oder sonst
zu elektrik elektrische geräte bringen
dann brennen die anders als jetzt
irgendwie ins sofa brennt oder sony
man könne natürlich auch einfach nur
sagen wir gehen davon aus dass das haus
am ende eben lichterloh brennt das ist
jetzt der endzustand das haus brennt
lichterloh
und da müssen wir jetzt nicht mehr
unterscheiden zwischen verschiedenen
arten des brandes und das haus steht
einfach in flammen
wohl unterscheiden flammen aber ich
glaube sie weiß noch den wichtigen punkt
die frage ist jetzt auch was nehmen wir
jetzt hier als wirkung an wir reden
jetzt sie immer nur über die ursachen
und von welcher wirkung sprechen
eigentlich weil dieses problem dass wir
hier mit den ursachen haben dass wir so
eine komplexe brand bedingung auch haben
dieses problem könnte sich auch noch bei
den wirkungen stellen
schreib dir selber am ende das relation
um existenzen sind so eine aussage über
das muss derzeit eher schon die wirkung
nur eine spezielle aussagen einführt
es ist der fall das vorher noch
aussetzen dann ist das nächste szene
auskennen
also keine tatsächlich aussagen über den
zustand also damit kann man auch nur
existenzielle begründung bekommen
vor einigen wochen steht das nicht
anders und dass er dann zeigt dass wenn
man eine wenn man sowas an
es ist der fall ist das ausbrennen ist
anders
ja also das ist ein ganz ganz schwerer
punkt und ich will jetzt hier noch mal
kurz mal kurz formalisieren erbracht
dass dann ja auch noch
also wir haben jetzt hier eine große
klammer und jedenfalls sie geben mir
widerstand oder sie schreibt ein wenn
ich falsch liege
es geht also eine komplexe bedingung die
hinreichend aber nicht notwendig wird
die für das feuer ist all das heißt wir
haben hier nur so ein fall
das ist dass hinreichende und innerhalb
dieser bedingung das ist die wurst das
ist letztendlich die ursachen
bedingungen da ist jetzt das ereignis
des kurzschlusses eben ein indiz
dispenser burkhard also ein
unverzichtbarer teil und es kommen eben
noch weitere randbedingungen mit hinzu
genau gelesen jetzt noch das nächste
zitat in disneys denn des accord chaos
ist neunte p an inception und es ist
jetzt diese berühmte konditionen also an
inception battery park of conditions stc
eines serbischen vaters expertise in
effekte des scholz secude ist in der
szene ist conditions of this sort der
diakonischen switch conjoint mit fischen
conditions of the house of the
importance of conditions of destruction
derby convenient nature conditions of
the world of conditions
also das ist jetzt ganz wichtig ich
schreibe es noch mal kurz ziel und wir
gehen da dann auch in der nächsten
sitzung noch mal ein bisschen genauer
drauf ein und das müssen wir jetzt
wirklich klar machen also - das ist
jetzt hier der erste satz also alle die
ursache ist
sagen sie es mir noch mal diese ganzen
bedingung die jetzt eine ursache
ausmachen also dieser reihenfolge nach
geht es ist also was nochmal das ist ja
ja
genau also inzwischen ja und dann was
kommt dann
genau wie das land anders smi sli und
dann am ende bat session fordern sollte
und dass er gibt jetzt hier diese -
bedingt also das ist jetzt sagen der
crew und das hat so eigentlich noch
niemand vor
mackey richtig an dieser komplexen
schachtel um dargestellt und das wollen
wir jetzt auch das haben jetzt mal so
weit erst mal gesehen und wir wollen
jetzt mit der nächsten sitzung weil die
heutige sitzung jetzt leider schon zu
einem ende gekommen ist in der nächsten
sitzung wollen wir uns dieses gefüge
dieser e-mails bedingung noch mal ganz
genau anschauen und vor allem fragen
trifft das zu damit sie einige
diskussionspunkte gehabt einmal ist die
frage ist das adäquat für diese konkrete
situation und dann kann man sich fragen
wie ist es eigentlich mit dieser wirkung
hier von welcher wirkung sprechen wir
von welchem feuer sprechen wir von einem
bestimmten feuer oder sprechen wir
einfach nur davon dass ein haus am
grundsätzlich brennt und zwar um
unterscheidbar brennt das haus steht
einfach in flammen
genau also genau dieses zu fischen ist
das hier das das hinreichend das ist das
praktisch hinreichend es ist nicht
notwendig sonst wäre es eben doppelt
fall und dann bezieht sich das auf die
innere bedingungen ja wir lesen das aber
im nächsten mal noch mal genauer und
versuchen uns ist auch mal ganz konkret
vorzustellen anhand dieses ausbruchs
dieses feuers und wollen fragen ob diese
bedingung wirklich unsere intuition von
kausalität fast oder ob sie nicht doch
noch weitere kritische einwände geht und
ich möchte eben noch mal darauf
hinweisen es geht um die frage auf was
für eine wirkung haben wir davon welcher
wirkung sprechen wir sprechen hier von
einem bestimmten feuer dass bestimmte
ausmaß hat oder sprechen wir einfach nur
ganz allgemein davon dass ein haus jetzt
feuer gefangen hat also wir werden jetzt
auch ein bisschen mit blick auf die
wirkung werfen müssen und nicht nur auf
die ursache in der nächsten sitzung
gehen wir da noch mal ein bisschen mehr
drauf 1 weil es heute leider ein
bisschen kurz und ich werde auch noch
auf die hausarbeiten eingehen haben sie
meinen merkblatt bekommen für die
erstellung von hausarbeiten überlegen
sie sich noch fragen der nächsten
sitzung werde ich auch noch mögliche
haus arbeitsthemen vorstellen dass wird
die dann noch kurz klären können dann
bis zur nächsten sitzung